he's got a real important job he is the
president of the nfl players association
jc treader and also the starting center
of the cleveland browns brown's
scheduled open the season in baltimore
on september 13th and jc kind enough to
join us where do we stand here what what
questions are left to be
answered from the side of the nfl
players association
yeah there's still quite a few we
obviously made some strides early in the
week on some of the safety issues
um those i don't really even consider
union wins at this point those were just
the right thing to do by the nfl and
we've been we've been fighting to
to get the nfl to look at this thing
understanding that football has to look
different there's no way to to foot
uh or fit coronavirus inside of football
you have to find a way to fit
football inside of coronavirus um you
know things like daily testing
uh things like no preseason games were
things that had to be done in order to
try to not just start a season but
finish a season so there's still a lot
a lot of work left to be done a lot of
questions left to be answered
but you go back to sunday and it felt
like an orchestrated
twitter salvo being fired by some of the
marquee players
to uh the nfl
did you organize that oh that was that
was player-led
and and that's the the thing about a
union the the players are the union so
was it union-led yeah the players
players organized it um
and i think that just shows that the
players
are very concerned about health and
safety very concerned about the health
and safety of their families
uh and they want these questions
answered and uh we've been working on
this for for months
uh and and it seems like it's taking
forever and and we continue to press the
nfl to provide us the answers that our
guys want
uh and some of those issues are still
outstanding we went from
what four preseason three preseason then
two one zero pretty quickly there
um why don't the players want at least
one pre-season game
so there's two issues one's the the
coveted side of it
where if you're creating these safe
bubbles at your facilities
what's the benefit to playing a game
mixing two groups risking an outbreak
for a game that doesn't count the
standings
and in doing so could derail the entire
season if something happens
second the football side of it and
something we're still fighting for is
the proper acclimation period
as well as ramp up and the more
pre-season games in the schedule
the shorter that ramp up can be and what
we learned from
the lockout season where gyms were
closed we had guys who didn't go through
a normal offseason program
we had a huge spike in soft tissue
injuries uh 25
increase overall 44 increase in
hamstrings twice as many achilles
injuries
so we have that data from before
understanding that we didn't do the
proper ramp up
10 years ago uh and now it's it's
necessary to do the proper ramp up to
make sure we take guys from where
they're at right now
to gain speed without rushing them back
and having a mass injury event
but you have a new head coach and kevin
stefanski just trying to get acclimated
to being on the field have
communications
up top and with your quarterback how do
you try to
have some kind of semblance of a game or
situational football where
he's able to do that without it just
being the first game of the regular
season
yeah i i trust uh i trust the coaches to
be able to figure out how to put us in
those positions in practice and put us
in
in situations that we can mimic live
game reps
uh mimic those situations and and get
ready for the game and
i i think that's that's possible without
preseason games
and you know how many if we were to play
one preseason game
backed up to the regular season how many
of the starters who you're talking about
getting ready
would have played in that game risking
injury anyway it just overall just
didn't make sense to slide one into the
end because i don't think it would have
done it would have did what it was
supposed to do
what about inner squad games do you see
that happening
well you mean uh between two teams or
just between
if you did two teams could could you see
that happening
that was the joint practice and and that
was a a recommendation from our joint
subcommittee
uh that again just like the combining of
bubbles during
the preseason games you didn't want to
fly a group out to another city
have them live in a hotel for for four
days in a non
you know bubbled environment and have
that risk of an outbreak
and that's the thing we've continued to
preach is we can we can easily get
started
it's about staying started and
continuing a season
uh and you can't make decisions to try
to you know prioritize the football
aspect of it and in doing so derail the
entire season
but you still remain confident that
you're going to start on time
well the nfl is allowed to open up the
facilities that's that's in their right
it's our job as a union to protect our
players and try to create and demand the
safest workplace possible so
uh the nfl and the clubs are going to
start bringing players back
all players back in the next week uh we
have
you know things in place to monitor them
and make sure they're taking
everything where we're putting into
place seriously and if they don't then
we'll have actions that we'll take to
make sure we keep our guys safe
uh and as guys report we'll we'll
continue to monitor that and make sure
everything's going well
but where things stand today though jc
are the players expected to report
if if the team uh players have contracts
so if the team
tells you to come back on the 28th as
long as it fits within the cba
you go back those are the rules and
that's why the union's pushing so hard
for protections
to make sure these these locker rooms
these facilities are put into place
and and up to code that guys aren't
being at risk by being at the facility
so that's what we continue to fight for
uh continue to demand uh and push the
nfl to make sure these are as safe as uh
environments as possible
if the facility was open today would you
show up
uh me no i don't have to be there till
the 28th no but if
it was open let's say if today was
reporting day
would you be there if today was the 28th
i would be there because i'm
actually obligated to be there okay the
antonio
antonio brown situation uh where does
the nfl players association what's the
role with them
because he said he was going to retire
now he says he wants the nfl to wrap up
their investigation so he can play again
what role does the players association
play in a player
is antonio brown still a member of the
union
uh i believe i mean if he's retired he
would be a non-active player
he's retired i think he's paperwork
yeah um i'll have to look into that i
didn't see that that report whenever
that came out about him retiring then
unretiring
so i have to look into kind of what we
can do uh to help
wrap up that situation but also get back
to you yeah i'm wondering about that
that
the commissioner doesn't look at this
and go boy it's antonio brown
let me wrap this up he's got to treat
everybody the same
but it feels like it's just been kind of
hanging out there
and that's why i was curious what the
role of the you know here you are the
president of the nfl players association
and if you even get involved in
something like that
or is it management that gets involved
in this uh well that would be more
probably a lawyer for us than me
i think antonio would probably rather
have the lawyer
[Laughter]
is this your home yeah
it's kind of sparse there i got i don't
have any curtains
like what's there we've got we've got
the pull down
uh shades uh blackout shades so they're
they're up high
minimalist that that's what we went for
where's the paintings
or or posters or something we got two
paintings over there some books
uh a very very uh a white white out
environment
do you have a weight room there uh i've
got one down in the basement
oh okay uh by the way uh
but we had you on june 16th and you and
mick lovin
had a bet based off cornell dartmouth
now that game is moved to the spring i
guess
so maybe you could attend
i heard the sigh of relief when that
announcement came out
i heard that out loud when he when he
got that news that he
he wouldn't have to face the the wrath
of cornell yes mclovin
well it's typical cornell get an
extension because you know you're not
going to do well on a paper that's
something jc knows really well
oh wow any response there jc
i mean if if they are going to play in
the spring i think i will have to make
an appearance
i think that's the only way to do it
mclovin yeah as long as i have to go to
ithaca in the spring
is there a good time to go to ithaca
make 11.
that's jc because i haven't been there
there's about a month and a half
it's the perfect weather uh hey great to
talk to you again
my best to your father who i uh know uh
watches the show
and uh hopefully we got football
starting here coming up soon but thank
you again jc
absolutely appreciate that that's jc
treader he's the head of the nfl players
association he's the president in the
cleveland browns
center